hello everybody hello everyone dorky bike is back okay let me give me a sec let me adjust my sorry i was a little late because i woke up late and um i had to i had to eat breakfast and it was at that time when i started eating breakfast it was already uh it was already 12 20 i was like you know what i ain't right i i'm tired i'm not rushing i i deserve my me time okay i deserve my me time donkey bug deserves good things sometimes in life i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna take my time and let it digest in my stomach um so that's why i am a little late today uh it's also like after Of course,
like I just set everything up because I forgot I got I got Not only did six of silk saw and got a patch.
I got a patch too So like you see how that um now now when I look up half my face doesn't disappear So I got my own little hot fix right now and also um I can be like bad dad bad Well he's gone
No more Now I'm bald.
The new, the 1.1 jokie update.
No!
This is worse than when they
do.
Yeet.
Oh, he comes back.
There he goes.
I'll be like, all right, dad, go inside.
And then I'm like, watch this.
Yeet.
I yeeted him out of hope.
Anyway.
before we begin oh wait let me uh i actually forgot that i bought this game on gog i was like what happened to my silk song where did it go did they delete silk song off my steam list they're like you haven't played you haven't played a game after four after two days we're we're the devs are like we're gonna delete the game off your steam list because you weren't committed enough all right let me i push play all right also sound guy i messaged in our the the sound team's uh discord group chat but i forgot to save the sound settings for silk song so i need your help in trying to help me figure out what what the settings are um you don't you didn't commit so we're deleting it off your steam list
week anyway before I before I begin um it's show it's it's not not only a dokey bug time it's show bug time okay where is it where is let me find let me find a bit so you guys didn't know you guys didn't know I'm gonna play the promo whoa yeah you know I should be blowing I should dance along to it.
Whoa, look at that, there's that!
Bap, bap, bap.
Bap, bap.
Yeah!
Look at that!
Look at all the PJs again, the rerun!
And there's the key chains again!
And there's the key chains, and there's exclusive bonuses like voice packs.
So yeah!
Look at all these items!
Oh my god, it's time to get ripped out!
with the Duel Keeper Gina Collection.
So yeah, for those who don't know, I have a apparel collection collab with Gina Draws.
I love her stuff.
I actually own several of her hoodies.
I actually bought some of her stuff pre- YouTubing times.
So it was such a fun, great, and great honor to collab with her.
And I guess I know there's two weeks left for pre-orders.
So get yours before it's gone forever.
I don't know if we're ever going to rerun of them.
So this is your chance to get the apparel collection before it's gone.
And we snap it out of existence.
But yeah, just a little chill bug time.
Other than that, nothing else.
Oh yeah, I almost forgot.
I was like, nothing else.
By the way, so I found out during yesterday's member stream.
Well, I didn't find out.
I just, like, remembered about it because I forgot.
A month and a half ago, they gave me an EA creator code.
And for those who don't know what creator codes are, it's basically like whenever you, it's like basically a Fortnite creator code where if you buy something, you put in like the creator code, like some of the revenue goes towards like the creator versus towards the company.
So I got that a month and a half ago and I forgot about it.
To be fair, I was traveling.
It was like I was literally like two days before I was traveling the guanjos So there was a lot of stuff going on.
So basically I might have missed out on the battlefield six for the creator code, but like But that means you can cancel your pre-orders and then re-pre-order it again with my creator Don't do that.
It's all right guys, so don't do that guys for legal reasons, don't actually do that because I don't want to actually get in trouble with EA.
So basically, if you use the creator code Dokeybird on any EA purchases, I don't even know if it works on skin, like, like Apex skins or anything.
I haven't used it yet.
Um, but if you buy anything on EA store and I legitimately didn't realize Battlefield 6 was E.
I don't know.
It just feels like, I don't know.
Like all these AAA companies sort of blurred together for me.
So I legitimately cannot remember any AAA company that does what game these days.
Because like they all sort of, they're like this like conglomerate that merged together like a fusion.
Because they're all the same to me.
So I legitimately forgot that EA made battle of battlefield um and because like you know i didn't have to also like i don't know it's just i just they all blurted together um um so yeah so yeah you can use my creator code jokeyberry um to so that some of the revenue doesn't go straight to ea go straight to me yay yay fund my bad spending their bad spending habits yippee
um anyway that's that's all the shilling i was gonna do today um other than that uh it's uh i'll give you guys a dad update dad update sorry my brain is really slow because it's a it's uh it's really slow because i just woke up i didn't have time to rev up the engine today so my brain is like little slow right now a little i know i'm always a little slow but like this is a little slower than usual dread fighter thank you for welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome that update um not much of an update it's just more so of him being a little piece of uh but um you know ever since he got i swear ever since he like recovered uh from surgery and his second injury um he's like He like doesn't care anymore He's like You only have one life on this earth On this world You gotta make it count Take your chances Life is short So yolo You only live once Anyway So Ever since ever since he's you know gone through two life-threatening injuries um he's been extra bratty and extra territorial and extra
aggressive towards other dogs um literally like we i would take him on walkies and he would see a dog from across the street literally across the street and it's like pretty far he would he would see a dog from across the street stare at him for like 10 seconds like stop he'll stop from the walk and then stare at them and then and then after 10 seconds he'll be like that what are you looking at bro that's right don't you dare cross this street This is my territory.
My home.
I'm going to pee on that grass so you don't know this is my area.
Don't you dare come here.
Don't you dare cross that street.
And, like, he would just bark at them.
I don't understand.
He's never done that before.
Like, I own this blog.
So, like, and...
And they'd be, like, just across the street.
The other dog is like, what the fuck?
Like, what are you?
Like, the other dog is just like, what's wrong with it?
Like, what's up with this guy?
Like, so, like, he's never done this before, before his injuries.
It's only after his injuries that he's, like, been challenging dogs from eight miles away.
And also, I guess another dad update.
Today on his, oh yeah, this happened today on his walk, but it's been happening a lot in his walkies.
Um, uh, basically like, uh, I was walking dad on this patch of grass and it's next to the road.
And there was this couple, um, in their car and the lady on the passenger seat, not the driver's seat on the passenger seat, just so you guys know it, on the passenger seat,
her boyfriend or like husband I don't know I don't see no ring and was like oh look at this cute little dog look at him look at that weenie dog it's so cute and they're like literally like right beside me like on the road and and then dad you know he looks up it was like oh I love attention especially from pretty ladies and then you know he was like he got his you know he like acknowledged him for like two seconds then he turns around and then starts pooping in front of the you know in front of her and he's like yeah you like what you see like and the lady instantly like instantly pulls the window back up because did not i do i don't think she likes what she saw i really i i don't know i have a suspicion that she did not like what she saw
it's the girl lady like it's like oh it's so cute what a cute dog look at it look at the weeder dog turns around just starts pooping in front of her hey babe she starts shitting on the floor
Yeah, and then they drove away.
Dumb wolf.
Then give him the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad, life's too short to wait for a girl to wake up to feed me.
Then give him the super chat.
Thank you.
Solid snake.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
At least with Doki, you can see where the money goes.
Like on Fortnite Jordan.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
By using your creator code on EA, I'll make sure to spend it on Air Jordan's on Fortnite.
Oh my god.
Oh, guys.
Okay, I did this on the Mem Machine, but I bought new shoes, but it's on Fortnite.
Look, I need shoes.
Okay, okay.
My current shoes might be like two plus years old, and I have only one pair of sneakers and one pair of sandals.
I've been wearing them for like two plus years, but you don't understand.
I need more shoes in my Fortnite closet.
I got them I bought it guys I bought converse and air jordans in fortnight so my beavers can wear his air jordans you don't understand beavers needed this he needs to be dripped out with his kicks you don't understand who needs real shoes when my virtual avatars are dripped out with kicks guys You don't understand.
Look, it's all about my reputation on Fortnite.
He needed...
My xenomorph needed his jays, okay?
Look, the other Fortnite players are gonna make fun of him.
He's not dripped out with the Jordans.
With his pumped-up kicks.
Guys, you don't understand.
I can't...
Guys.
Real Jordans get creases.
Virtual Jordans in Fortnite will stay pure forever.
The value can only go up.
Anyway.
All right.
Silk song time.
Yippee.
Some of you guys might be wondering.
Wow.
Doki.
Why did you wait so long to play Silk song?
part two because i was getting fucking tired of getting lost okay i was so tired of getting lost and like being on random side quests on fighting bosses that i shouldn't even be fighting i was so i was look guys i legitimately thought we were making really good progress on silk song during the launch because i was like wow look at all these all the areas i've explored oh my god i must have unlocked like 70 70 to 80 of the map by now and then like you know two days later because that's how fast people it takes for people to like complete the game i guess two days later i saw the actual map and i was like I was only,
you know how I was like, surely it can't get worse, you know, surely, surely the jail is the worst part of, um, of silk song.
I was wrong.
It does get worse.
It, I, I saw an area.
Um, I was spoiled for an area because, you know, my for you page is like all silk song now.
And, and then like, I saw an area.
I won't spoil it yet for those who have not like seen the rest of silk song and are also just in the jail.
area, it does indeed get worse.
It gets a lot worse.
Not only do the enemies, not only is it the environment that gets worse, it's like the end.
Oh, the jail gets a lot worse.
I was like, surely that's it, right?
Surely the, what I've seen so far of the jail area with the dogs and the poison swabs, that's it, right?
No, I, I know what comes, what comes after in the jail area.
It's all downhill.
It's all downhill from here.
But I've merely only unlocked, I think, like, 30% of the map, which is crazy because I feel like I explored so much within the first stream.
There's apparently a super jail.
I thought I was already...
I was like, there's a super jail.
i thought there was only one jail what do you mean a super jail what crimes do i have to commit to get into super jail like like i was like oh my i feel like it's like maximum security in jail
so so yeah that's why um that's why i also waited a while before i played silk song just because I knew that by the time I play do a part two like everybody will already be done with the game like I I know you guys you guys waited seven years I know you haven't put down the game since it came out so I was like okay I'll just wait and then then finally finally I can be guided to the right way uh I was like by that time people would have beaten the game and then I can be
I won't be lost anymore um also uh for those who don't know um silk song did end up getting nerfed and um and uh they nerfed a couple of that's also why I waited that's like
that's also why I waited but also the worst part is that it didn't even matter that I waited because they nerfed all the bosses that I've already beat I was like are you serious are you fucking they weren't even the hard ones too for me okay apparently more wing and the the tree mom or whatever the fuck she I don't even know her name like I killed her first try like um what's like I killed her second try and so I like I didn't even register her name um so uh they nerfed the the more fly or whatever giant bug um at the that does like that shasha shasha shasha and you know everything this time also i found out that 80 of the enemies in this game does times two damage like what the i was like what's the point of giving us like just just delete our hp like don't even give us six like giving us six hp was a lie like that's not it's not even just gave us three at that point HP and then everything does one damage if that's the case like why did they lie to us it gave us me a full false sense
of security with all that HP they gave me like hornet's frail body she's so one of her broons made of fucking glass oh my i swear to god like you're like no it's me silk is actually really really strong do you not see me fucking slashy slashy with my silk
I feel like I my my HP is like Zimbabwe currency.
It's like a million It's like worth a minute like you see that it's a million dollars, but it's actually worth three dollars like Like the fucking my health inflation is only going up Just don't I just don't get hit toky
Yeah, inflation is rough on Silk Song.
Anyway, Silk Song had a nerf, and so they nerfed.
Apparently, they also, like, they nerfed the economy of Silk Song.
So, yippee!
The market crashed in Silk Song, and we're now in the Great Recession, because now benches are cheaper.
Yay!
I was just like, thank God.
No, I knew it.
I knew it.
During launch, I was, like, making all these comments.
being like okay the rosary shit like this is it's so hard to like farm money it's like really hard to farm money and it's everything is so fucking expensive and all that shit and i knew it i knew it was i knew it i was just like i can't be the only one complaining i was like why is everything so expensive like how bad is capitalism right now in silk sign oh my god i'm waiting for That's why I waited too.
I waited for the bubble to burst so I can head to the Great Recession in Silk Song.
Because I, I, I, what was it called when you bet against the stocks?
I was one of those people that bet against the stocks.
And now I am the millionaire because I waited.
I shorted.
That's right.
I was shorting the Silk Song stocks by waiting.
I was I shorted silk song I bet against the market I knew it so now benches are apparently a lot cheaper now and think like it's easier to farm rosaries now so I'm like thank fucking god I finally got what I deserve and so like during lunch I was like am I bad like you know because like it felt so hard i was like there's i was like wait the fuck like i had such an easy time in hollow night and then getting the silk song you know it took me like several tries for bosses versus like first trying like bosses in hollow night and i was like so confused i was like there's no way like did i there's no way i got worse in between because like i there was barely And then,
like, you know, after that stream, I saw people suffering even more, which made my heart grow two times that day, just like the damage I take.
And, yes, I did take enjoyment out of other people's pain, and you can't judge me on this.
You watch me play this game for the same reason.
You're just like me.
I am the mirror into your soul.
so i was like oh thank god everyone else is worse than me i was like thank god i'm still a gamer
the day my ego grew three times larger um and like like i said it was like everyone was complaining about the times two damage and um and fucking savage beast fly I knew that fucker was hard.
I was like, there's no way.
There's no way that I am the only one suffering from this goddamn fucking stupid bug.
There's no fucking way.
And then my entire timeline was just people like complaining about him and being like, I've beaten this boss.
So I beat, I defeated all this.
I won all, I finished all Souls games.
I did like, I completed all the endings of Hollow Knight.
But this guy, this guy.
And I'm like, I knew it.
I knew.
feel so vindicated i was like validation five my god i spending was it less like 40 minutes on this i knew i wasn't the only one and i was the fact that i was able to brute force it with no upgrades or the side tools because i did it no better i literally launched i nobody knew i i this is also why i waited too by the way I was not going through another beast fly.
I'm not going through another savage beast fly situation where I get sidetracked into a boss fight that didn't fucking matter and that didn't that didn't fucking matter and gave me nothing.
It gave me apparently the beast crest is the one the worst crest out there.
So it didn't fucking matter.
No, it didn't matter.
Everyone was Like, that Chris fucking sucks.
And I'm like, what?
But I spent 40 minutes on these.
You cannot tell me that my reward is considered emptier for how much pain I went through.
But, Dukie, you got a clue.
It doesn't matter.
Never again.
Never, never again.
So, yeah, no one knew better back then.
I hope he never gets nerfed and we all suffer and cry for the future generation.
I hope your great, great grandchild picks up Silk Song and goes through savage beast fly in his original form.
Because if I had to, the whole world...
world has to today on turkey's daily my feelings are valid
all right all right anyway let's actually play the game so i have to go through sorry guys i had to trauma dump a little bit before i go all right here we go let it all out Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you not also.
I forgot how to play this game Um, it's it's been a while.
Okay, this is Matt.
I might I waited and now I also forgot how to play this game Um, let's see it Um Wait
Uh, why am I like why am I low?
Wait, give me a sec I forgot to
Give me a sec, guys.
Am I longer?
Am I legs longer?
Wait, it's not.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I crashed out and then all my stuff is not working.
Oh, no.
Guns working.
My legs are extending.
It's really hard to see because the map is like...
The map is so dark.
I was like, are my legs extending, guys?
What happened to my leg surgery?
My leg extendo surgery.
I paid top dollar to be a little taller.
All right, give me a sec.
I realize I messed up a little bit.
I want to move myself up just a little bit.
There we go.
All right, there we go.
I want to move myself up.
I want to look a little taller.
there we go that's right now I'm a little taller
hello and hearing awful whispers in camp about pilgrims driven mad by the hardship of the climb crying out and attacking their fellows you've been out there tell me is it really so You've heard it true, sir.
On the roads, both pilgrims and beasts alike are consumed, driven into violence by a haunted thread, the source of which I have yet to discover.
I fear it will so.
I won't be able to trust a single face on the path then.
The risk of death was daunting enough, but Lonius is such a journey that seems almost too much to bear.
Ah, well, just another test of our devotion, I suppose.
Rest here with me as long as you like I'm not ready to leave yet And a little company is always nice Okay Alright goodbye Where do I run?
Okay Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee I love that run I love my What's it called when When the dog gets really My zoomies I love my little zoomies Won't you stop and make a trade Oh my gosh, I'm so...
Okay, let's go get some money, actually.
Also, do I have all the maps?
Okay, I just forgot I don't have double jump.
Yes, got it.
Alright.
Oh, no, none of these matter.
Okay, where is a good place to farm again?
I gotta remember where to farm.
Baby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I can bring up the overall volume.
I wonder if I can do it here.
can nice all right aida aida you know what wait i want to be i want you to see my i want to like levitate a little bit all right yeah you can do your little zoomies tail give me a sec i'm just fixing some overlay did i feel like super okay by the way today is gonna be a little bit of a shorter stream like um from how long my usual streams are uh just because that I want to save my voice today um and not straining it too much so we're not going to do another 10 hours like last time we'll do nine hours don't worry guys we'll do nine hours instead of 10 I don't guys okay now that we all know now oh wait I have to go to the god fucking I have to go to the jail cell I oh yeah also I found out the stupid fucking more wing shit you can actually get like a helper to help you kill them too but he wasn't that hard okay for me I didn't realize more wing was considered one like the hardest like one of the first filters for like new were players because for me i didn't find him that difficult um um
but apparently for the fly thing here yeah i i didn't think it was that bad but also like you know um i do have really good reflexes so i can under like um i can bypass that so uh but there's actually a helper you can get from here that that also assists in your fight and help you like uh kill like help you kill him Um...
I think it's more so of like, it's just basically like, if you have the reflexes and stuff.
It's just like a ref- like a reflex test.
Because for me, it was fine.
I didn't have that much of a bad time.
Because I was like, am I for you?
People were like saying how they got stuck on- on him.
Like, people were saying how he- they got stuck on him for hours, even with- what's his name?
Zanzibar?
all right we go we have the farm rosaries because um i need money i'm broke and i don't remember okay guys i need to like test it out for these guys okay i like need to remember how to play this game so i'm gonna test it out by beating up the monks all
right come on get over here.
Please, I need to... Please get over here.
I need to remember how to play this game.
Let me kill you.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, he's so annoying.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
He didn't win.
I'm healing.
I was healing guys.
He didn't win.
Okay.
No, I don't like that flow too much.
Sorry, I'm like super anal about this.
It ain't natural.
We're the ground at.
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god, I feel so slow right now.
I actually feel so slow.
I'm literally like fighting these guys to like remember how to play.
also apparently this quest is not the best too but i like it i was telling my friend to like who my one of my friends who's also play playing uh silk song i was like when they started before after me i was like oh you should get this quest you should oh it's so good the reaper quest and then they're like i just watched a tier list video the reaper is like one of the worst ones i'm
They're like, um, actually, um, the Reaper quest is actually one of the worst ones, so I don't know why you're using it.
I'm like, oh, it's good for...
In my heart, it's good!
Okay, oh my god, bro, fuck off.
Apparently, because it's, like, one of the slower ones.
and i could try to defa i like it for the magic honestly
goodness all right we got farm till we're jesus christ why can't i fucking oh my god she's just throwing rocks at me
i mean all right what are the other crests oh my god how do i how do How do I do this?
Okay, here we go.
I guess the other crest would be...
It would be the default.
I'm not gonna try it out and see how I feel.
Uh...
Try that.
How do I use the weapons again?
How do I use the weapons?
My extra weapons?
Oh wait.
Adidas!
Uh, was it R?
R-L-R-B?
Oh, okay, there you go.
I didn't think of the super chat thing.
Yeah.
Reaper is good.
Your friend is a casual.
Adidas!
There you go.
I don't even remember what, like, the special feature is for...
Uh...
For...
For the magic.
of the default one.
Alright,
we all get 500.
So I can get the key.
It's farming time.
Adidas!
That's fine, I don't really care.
You're just here to be farmed.
That's right.
That's your only purpose in life.
To be farmed.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I forgot you jumped.
I think the hard part is just remembering of the dash.
The dash is the downward dash throws me off because it's slightly slanted.
Remember that Reaper let you poke a strain, therefore made it easier.
Therefore, your friend is categorically wrong.
You're right.
Everything I say is the right way.
You're so right.
guys anything that's not that's not my opinion anything that doesn't follow my opinion is wrong free speech but only my speech is the free one glad so thank you in the super chat thank you thank you
all right nice we're almost at 500 uh-oh i controlled i narrative.
The freedom of speech kordokie version.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, now I don't have silk anymore.
Remember when I was really rich and then I lost it all because I got sent to super jail?
Wait, no, I haven't got to super jail yet.
I just got to regular jail.
I... Oh my god.
What are they gonna do in super jail?
Are they gonna take my clothes?
Get you out of here.
Oh, no, my money.
Alright, let's go here.
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chog's only Pogo diagonally.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Groundhog.
Back to Groundhog Day for these guys.
Adidas!
My... No, get out of there!
How would I farm you if you die?
I'll do it.
I don't even know how...
Oh yeah, also... That's also why I waited.
Because I need people to...
I need people to help me figure out how to get an upgraded nail.
Never again.
We're not letting this happen again.
I'm not having a repeat of Hollow Knight.
I need to know how to get my upgraded nail.
Upgrading the nail is very hard.
I need a...
It's a sacrifice I must make.
I cannot finish this game on plus two damage.
I...
Oh, we're farming for...
I should have done this off stream.
I should have done...
I should just farm the rosaries off stream.
I just forgot how...
I just forgot that...
how tedious this is to farm rosaries.
Am I at 500 yet?
Okay.
Okay, almost there.
418.
Yeah, but I want to get the key.
The simple key.
I don't have it.
Oh my god, I was trying to oh my god give me a stride up i was not paying i was trying to figure out how do i i was like oh my tools i gotta use my tool and then instead i just instead of pressing up rb i was pressing my map i was like oh up like my map my map button yeah i don't care anymore Yeah
No, it's like it's 500 I literally saw is she fucking a she raised her prices We are in the great recession and you're raising your prices
Oh wait, I thought I had JK.
Oh my gosh, I legitimately thought It's fine I thought I had Um, more silk.
Alright, nice, we're almost done.
It's called a monopoly.
There's no way she has all the keys.
I refuse to believe it.
Alright, one more time.
Adidas!
Alright, that should be it, right?
Yeah, there we go.
I have enough now.
Alright.
to free up I can use the key okay guys okay so I didn't get spoiled that much but the reason why I'm getting a key is because I know for the key I can either do two things I can either use it for myself to get a quest or be a good person and free free a man free an innocent man from jail and because I am a I am going to get a crest
for you Look guilty until proven innocent guys We don't know if he actually We don't know if he's actually In this We don't know what crimes he had committed We don't know him He's not He's not going anywhere He's
Rest you with me.
Okay, I got it.
I wanted to take the bench.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
You think you...
What?
I killed you!
Oh, no.
Why are you back?
I killed you!
How did you come back?
You think he's bad?
do you think he's okay oh my god I was expecting a fight I thought you're dead oh my god I'm not ready for a boss fight right now I'm actually not mentally prepared for this I'm not mentally prepared for this I was not ready I don't even oh my god I don't even have my magic crest my Run to my fence!
How would I heal down?
Oh my god, I wasn't ready.
Oh, I was not ready.
I am not ready whatsoever for a fucking boss fight.
Oh my god!
Oh!
friend okay okay i'm locking in i'm locking it i was still like in farming mode
i was oh i was still in farming mode i literally just came back
jesus christ i don't even have like my actual okay blocking in blocking in
oh god no that's not fair that's not fair that's
my okay there you go there's my silk oh my god i'm not okay i'm not he's throwing off my group guys he's throwing on my crew.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, that was not the right move.
That was...
Here we go.
I shut the lock in.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, that's not okay.
That is not okay.
Sir, sir, sir, sir.
Okay.
Please, please leave.
You were, please, I swear, it was a make a wish.
It was a make a wish!
I had to kill you!
It was for a child!
Okay.
All right.
We got better.
I had to kill him!
It was a make a wish child!
Cream!
Oh my god.
Alright.
Oh my god, please.
He's so tanky.
This is why we need the nail upgrade.
This is exactly why we need the nail upgrade.
He's so tanky.
Oh my god, fucking worse.
Right.
Oh no.
Oh, we did it.
Guys, I think...
Guys...
I think he killed the make-a-wish kid.
I think this was the child.
That's fucked up, man.
That was his make-a-wish.
That's so fucked up.
The shop is gone!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I just got $500!
I...
I just I came back for the key And don't even get my key Oh my What's the point No he's still here Oh my god Are we How could it be That brave such a world Oh my I'll need more roses That's for sure Please travel Oh thank god Thank god I didn't get one guy I had to make sure How did I kill No that child That child caused own death he made a wish all right it's not my fault he made his wish and he didn't make it it's not my fault and here she is safe after all i was worried your battle that enormous beast had left you badly wounded james to have you left in danger there but see if i'm no warrior my tools ain't no match for a creature like that.
Benefragus.
It's well that you kept yourself safe.
This settlement needs a fixer now.
Not a warrior.
Maybe that's true.
Times like this, these all we can do is put our heads down and try to rebuild.
No, no.
This child, this child caused his own death.
Should have made that wish, kid.
Should have made that wish.
That's on him.
It's not my fault.
His wish caused this.
You have to keep the monkey paw curls.
Look, all I'm...
His makeup wish was literally, I don't like this guy.
Please kill him.
Hello, I have cancer.
I don't like him.
Please kill this guy.
And then I was like, okay, just for you.
You made that wish.
wish and now look what happened look wishes have consequences child maybe he should have made that wish he didn't make it in the end all right yeah see that wish was evil that boss had a that literally i told you eliminate the bloodline or they'll if you don't eliminate the bloodline come back for revenge this is what happens look at that wait wait maybe you should not have look it's not my fault i needed money okay it's not stop this is a great recession we all need we all need money right now okay this is exactly why okay so what is actually better do we get the do we the key at the deep docks or do we use it to free a man that might still that might actually be guilty we don't know uh black fire thank you the akasupa thank you thank you you always bring a smile to my face when i watch your stream i hope you treat yourself to something and thank you thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you um at least stay for it uh funeral i don't even know this person i i was just hired help
okay to make a child's dream come true it's not my fault that his dreams ended up making causing him to die okay at least he got his dream come true okay at least that's he got his dreams come true it's not my fault he died um oh it's for a tool not quest why get a tool or do i save an innocent man from jail I think I'll get it to a...
Will this innocent... Will this man even help me?
That's the question.
Yeah, I am... You're hired to fulfill dreams.
Not to...
Not to go to funerals.
Man does not...
I was like, does the man even help me?
Yeah.
You might want to check the moss, grotto, sit it.
Where the fuck is that?
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Save a life or get a cool screwdriver.
I don't know.
That screwdriver looks mighty cool.
Sounds mighty cool right now.
Can you get tools or that thing?
Okay, wait.
start oh the jail doesn't need a key it doesn't you mean the one down here
yeah the shoe driver sounds mighty cool it's like right here right
don't get one guy he's like i was gonna say i remember he's laughing that thing all right we use the key or do you free a free and innocent man supposedly didn't come around instead of a key
screwdriver all right free that quote-on-quote innocent man look what if I free him and he ended up being like a mass murderer we don't know that we don't know his life story he could literally be lying to us about his story we free him and then he kills more people that's on us then you can take care of him yeah but he was in jail i could just keep him in jail wait there's a path on top okay but can i use the key can i make that path right now oh i need more upgrades to even explore that area okay that's enough for me all right he has confirmed the prince i even heard that he's a nigerian one so he might give you a million dollars if you free him i don't remember how to navigate this area i'm actually so confused i i can sort of tell i'm not like mentally okay right now i'm i'm I'm like,
my mind's a mess at the moment.
I'm like, where am I going?
What buttons am I pressing?
I feel so slow.
Okay, we go back to the...
Okay, where do we go?
Where am I supposed to go?
Use the key at wormway here?
Oh, here?
Where do we go?
Worm...
Oh, the wormways?
Okay, we'll go to the...
How do I get to the wormways?
Okay.
I'm I'm like thinking okay, we go from the bones Oh, oops Not okay, right I'm actually like just confused I'm like you like the the granny at the time I'll be like granny you're you're obviously it's time for bedtime and like no you don't understand I gotta I gotta beat up some bugs.
You don't like sure doki You gotta beat up some bugs.
You can do that in bed.
Tomorrow.
Let's get you the bed, Granny.
Okay, it's this way.
Is it this way?
Yeah.
We don't need the bench.
Okay, let's beat up.
Let's get some money real quick.
When?
Oh my god, that's a stupid dash.
I forgot that this one is a dash.
It's fine.
I tanked it for a while reason.
And then here.
Can I head to wormways this way?
Hope so.
Hope we're here we go.
So this way?
Yeah.
Actually, I might need you.
Oh, I never mind.
Okay, no, I can still heal from it.
Let's see.
This way, we just go left.
Left side, left side.
Alright, there you go.
Alright.
Simple key.
It cost me one child and 500 rosaries.
Better be fucking worth it.
Oh.
Ew.
Okay, that's on me.
I'm not paying attention.
That is a 100% on me.
What?
Okay.
Maybe I should have got the bench.
Guys, I think I should have got the bench.
Wait, can I farm these?
Oh, I can!
Nice.
Okay.
When?
Wait, down?
Oh, okay.
Alright, down.
I go quest time quest time okay I was oh oh my god Jesus Christ that scared the shit out of me it's a fucking alien shit I thought it was gonna be like a giant worm it's just oh my god I hate I hate that now I can't see yeah
That felt like some xenomorph shit.
Alright, let's be full HP too.
Oh, secret!
What's this secret?
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
Extra lag!
What?
What was that?
Huh?
Yeah.
Why can't I farm you?
What is that?
What do I get out of it?
Oh, I can't use it?
Okay, now I'm in another secret.
Where the fuck?
What do I do here?
What?
Oh, is this a quest area?
Okay, now I'm in another secret that gives me nothing.
There's nothing!
Yippee!
Oh shit.
Wait, what?
It brought me back here?
You get absolutely nothing.
Fuck yeah, I love nothing.
Oh my god, nothing for three?
Oh my god!
I'm so lost.
I am so lost.
Where am I going?
Oh my!
That's on me.
Oh shit, Ness, I got it.
I got a memory locket.
In the spikes it seems.
I'm not okay right now.
Please tell me there's an easier way.
Not a good day for Doki.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
I need those like snake things I can farm right now.
I'm scared.
Literally like a paper can blow at me and I'll die.
I'll die from the impact.
Nice.
I need these.
That's actually what I need.
Alright, let's just farm these guys.
Dude, my mind today is really, really slow.
I wasn't lying.
It's very slow today.
Okay.
Alright.
Up, right?
I gotta get there.
Oh my god.
What the?
Get out of here.
Yeah?
Wait, which way?
Okay, guys.
Which way?
No, this is where I went.
Up, then, right.
This way?
Oh, my God.
I thought you'd be, like, here?
Okay, down?
I don't know.
Have I been down here yet?
Oh, the farms are stuck real fast.
The worm way.
I guess I'll go here.
Oh, no.
No!
Okay.
Guys, I'm okay.
I just keep wall grabbing for no reason!
Up and up?
Where's up?
Oh my god, where am I?
I'm so lost.
I just keep grabbing the sidewalk.
So annoying.
Wait, upwards?
I can't even go up.
go up a different way?
Right for...
Oh my gosh, I didn't even see him.
Right for now, okay.
Yeah, because I'm gonna...
Oh, these...
These fuckers!
Okay, I need to farm them.
Wait, where is...
Oh, no, this is... Oh, this is another of these.
Go down?
Okay.
Alright, down.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Where is this place?
I've been here before?
Greater down.
I'm like, where is this?
I don't think I've been here before.
I'm worried about going two down.
Oh, I'm going two down.
Oh, I'm going two down, guys.
Guys, I'm going two down!
Oh.
Where am I now?
Is this place?
Money!
Oh.
Alright, I guess I entered this house.
This scary house.
It's a home invasion of the scariest house ever.
Oh!
I'm home invading a church!
Oh yeah, that makes it a lot better.
Oh, shit.
That's fine, it's just a little flesh wound.
Ha ha!
That took you right.
I knew your plans.
I know what you are.
You're a coward.
Oh, no.
Fuck it.
Just Adi does it.
Alright, let's fight these monks with no battle training whatsoever.
Their faith will guide them the victory.
Toki, they have their faith!
Alright, yeah.
Maybe if they believe hard enough, they can do one damage to me.
Oh, I do have...
No, I don't have my minds.
I didn't equip it.
Wait, what the fuck?
Adias!
Oh my god, they did it.
See, I told you!
If they believe hard enough!
Oh my god, wait, they actually had me in the corner.
Oh my god, their faith is- their faith build is working!
Their faith build is actually working!
Okay, no, never mind.
It was false hope.
It was a false prophet.
Okay, we need to do that.
That's a shortcut.
And they're believing...
They're believing too hard!
Stop them!
What's this?
Let's kill this burrito.
Cut swiftly and nimbly with short, precise strike.
Okay, what's this?
What is this?
Oh,
go!
Oh, my god!
Now I'm calling that now.
I'm John Holliday It's time baby mode has success replayed a lot.
Let's go.
I finally got my crutch Finally
Finally I got my crutch Oh my god This is what dreams are made of this is what dreams are made of We did it.
We're finally unhandicapped.
It's just that easy.
I can pogo now.
Get out of here.
Wait, actually, we need that.
Yeah.
Oh, I can quit as well?
Wait, that's insane.
I think the only issue is that it's super short range, right?
Go right to unlock a door.
Yeah, this is me just using the hornet skin from all night.
Alright, unlock.
Yeah, I felt super short range.
Hello.
Oh, you're asking my permission?
Feeling curious, were you?
There's a vast graveyard.
I see most bugs die climbing the path, but see as many fell before the trek that had barely commenced.
Quangy.
Lost her lives to beast.
Or to lectern rotten.
Others were simply formed too frail.
At least those poor souls can get us thrusted together.
Death and death and death.
Eternal promise of eternal kingdom.
Eventually, it claims us all.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh my god, I forgot it doesn't have my It doesn't have my, uh, any of my stuff equipped.
Oh, shit, look, there's the funeral.
Goodbye.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
I don't even know that kid.
It's like inviting, like, oh, wait, my shaman.
It's like inviting fucking Jerry from the office to come to your funeral.
Go attend the funeral.
my fault.
I don't even, I don't even know his name.
What was his name?
Guys, I will attend his funeral if I know his name.
I bet none of you know his name.
I was paid to make his wish come true.
That's different.
Fine.
Little pilgrim.
What ritual calls you all together, pilgrim?
Our brother, this poor wretch in my, oh my bro, he's dead.
Don't We don't need to call him a wretch.
That's pretty fucking messed up.
He's already dead.
We gather here to sing him farewell, and to Amar and our great loss.
Below us pilgrims, we aim our sights high and never weaver from our path.
The loss of a brother or sister still stops our trembling limbs in place.
Sing brothers and sisters.
Sing and drown out this burdensome sorrow.
Sing out the name of this poor pilgrim whose journey had never begun.
Hmm.
We here knows the name of this little pilgrim.
Oh.
My.
Oh my god.
None of us even got his name!
Why am I here?
None of you even cared about this man.
This child.
Though this pilgrim's name has been lost.
So we sing.
Sing for our brother who was down a devout death all his pains and torments left behind like the dust struck from a traveler's shawl farewell little pilgrim may your shell harden the path for others to tread that's so you guys didn't even know you guys didn't even bother to know his name until he's dead that's fuck at least i went out there and made his wish come true even though he died for it but i still did it
Grave of the nameless bug.
Okay, now where do we go?
Wait, what are we supposed to do now?
You do not care.
Don't lie.
I can see it in your faces.
Oh, wait.
You need to kill us.
No!
I can go back to him.
I care.
You didn't even know his name.
Shellwood to Bellheart.
What the fuck is Shellwood?
Oh, that's Shellwood.
What do we do at Shellwood?
Yeah, what?
Alright, let me...
I need to kill this one bug holding this.
Okay, I need this bug to fly over.
I know he's there.
I literally saw him with my...
Oh, there he is.
There we go.
I needed this.
Nice.
Oh yeah, I need to, like, fix my...
Got my wish.
I need to fix my crush shit.
Alright, compass.
And then...
I need Adidas.
Here we go.
The right top in shellward takes you to the top.
Alright.
Where's that?
Oh, here?
Okay, we gotta go here.
We gotta take this away.
Okay, we gotta go take the tram.
Tram time.
Alright, let's get our nail upgrade.
Ada!
Alright.
Show- Oh, wait, that's Bellheart.
Wrong area.
Alright.
Gotta go who shall we?
This way.
It's so weird.
I keep thinking I have double jump for some reason.
And then we go this way.
I think I have my GPS.
bug PS.
Why do I...
I missed this way?
Okay.
Then we go this way, and then this way.
Alright, right side.
That's a pogo feel?
I don't know.
I don't know about... Oh, what the fuck?
Where are you doing here?
Who let you outside?
You didn't...
You forgot to wear your helmet.
Oh, my ma!
Look here, Miss Growno.
Very fascinating creature here.
All dead in bits now, but still good.
She takes the shape of the woods for her body, and her hair like bitter leaves.
Clever thinks new.
This creature is stacked to stake this territory here and attacked as I pass through.
You should not linger long.
A tribe remains hidden among the branches, the skies and waiting to strike.
Oh, so the cutting out was done by you?
You gives her warm thanks.
Now you can expect this creature well.
All its gooey insides and crunchy shell.
Okay, maybe you should never be allowed outside.
I'm sorry, buddy.
You are not socially developed enough to be a...
out here you're please please talk to a real person before you go out okay right side oh shit oops okay it makes pogo it makes parkour easier okay I don't know what he's barking about this is what I mean he's been like super bratty Alright, now up, Grin.
Whoops.
It's a little faster, though.
Okay, it's 2 p.m.
There's no way he's hungry.
Wait, what the fuck?
Can I kill him?
I'm gonna try and kill him.
Yeah, I can.
Thank god.
Oh my god, I don't know what he's barking about.
me a sec oh
yeah he's such a little shit okay it's because i i forgot to move the stairs this is because okay um i let him up my bed only at night when i sleep so i forgot to move the stairs away uh when i woke up so he was like come back you know like the the alexander helmet so i mean that's going around TikTok and YouTube,
where he's like, Alexander, come back to bed.
And I was like, I need to go to work.
So she's like, come back to bed, Alexander.
I'm like, come back to bed, Tokyo.
Please, I wanna sleep in bed with you right now.
He's literally like barking at me from the stairs.
Mama's got to make that money.
It's so dark outside.
So he was literally barking at the stairs.
Asking me to come back to bed.
What's this?
Okay.
Oh, hey.
It's a sleeve.
Back here, chat.
I don't think there's supposed to be children.
This has to be a dog.
You just don't believe they're kids.
I should run, but also I'm scared.
Oh, wait.
I'm going backwards.
Yeah, but they're like, My child, our child.
Please save our children.
It must be like children in a sense where like, you know, people treat their dogs as kids.
That's how I see it.
Okay.
know which way to go.
I'll go to the secret.
Oh, it's money.
Now I know where it's where to go.
Are they dog or child?
Okay, I could probably do this.
That's fine.
I hate how, like, I, like, grasp I, like, accidentally grasp the um, the walls sometimes.
It's so annoying.
Oh, what?
What?
Oh, I have to hit.
Oh, shit!
I saw him come.
No, no, I'm back here.
I saw him coming down.
I was like, this does not look so good for me.
This does not look good.
I was going to get crushed.
It was literally a death machine.
Show him.
Yeah, they made me a dokey sandwich right there.
Has to be a chair here, right?
Is there a chair here?
Oh, it's all the way.
Oh, fuck it.
I'll take the chair.
We need a chair right now.
There you go.
I wish I...
The one thing I don't like at the moment is the tools has to be up RB.
I wish it was like a different...
a different button.
I can't re-bind that, right?
I'm like, what do I bind it with?
That's the thing.
There's not a lot of buttons on the controller.
Well, I unlocked a shortcut.
I have?
I can.
Okay, I think I want to I want to bind it something.
But then, like, I'm like, what?
I guess like, oh, I could have it bind it to.
Left trigger.
is that what option controller what is else oh it's for harpoon i don't have a harpoon yet i guess r3 maybe i don't know i just don't like i don't know i'll try i'll keep using the I was like, Harpoon, the fuck is that?
I've never seen the Harpoon yet.
Oh.
R3 is Taun?
Do I have a Taun?
What the fuck does the Taun do?
Adoki is Taun's.
That's exactly what it does.
But like, what's the point?
Like, it's
for aura farming.
You'd understand if you had aura.
Where is he?
Okay, I was gonna say where the fuck is he?
Okay, I want to find this guy for a string just in case.
Just in case I don't make it.
You know?
Goodbye.
I just float any part of the way, water, water.
Any part of the way, water, water.
there hello get down hello I said in my uber that I don't want you to talk to me I my uber specifically oh my god my uber specifically said I don't want you to talk to me oh my I used to press the wrong button I pressed the wrong button oh This is so bad.
I did the same thing.
My, where is my...
Wait, did I grab my...
Oh, I already grabbed it.
I don't even know when I grabbed it.
Keep going down, buddy.
Keep going down.
God,
you fucker!
I'm gonna kill him.
I hate- I don't know why I keep accidentally, um, oh shit.
I just keep accidentally pressing, uh, like holding onto the walls.
It's so annoying.
Wait, what?
Am I missing something?
I keep accidentally, like, walking into the walls.
What?
Yeah, I'm outta here.
There we go.
Breakable- oh, here!
I didn't see that!
I know you're breakable.
Alright.
Oh, there's another breakable wall.
Wait, which way do I go?
We'll go this breakable wall first.
Oh!
I'm so nervous.
I'm so paranoid right now.
Like, I'm really paranoid over everything at the moment.
It feels like...
It's just death everywhere.
Are you serious?
I'm not used to how short the range is now.
I'm not used to it at all.
Yeah, I just wanted to share what that is.
Because like, her default is so...
It's so long.
Get down.
Oh, what the fuck you live that?
I'm so used to the far range of her regular weapons.
Okay, here's the shortcut.
Can I go up?
Oh, I can.
But Pogom!
Yeah, I know, but it's just, it's such a short range.
Wait.
I messed up.
I'll go down now.
I know, sir, you're blocking it.
I gotta parkour that.
Oh, there, that's how.
I don't know why I keep thinking I can...
What the... Oh my god, it's a creepy fucking basis.
There you go.
What's this?
Oh, more money.
Actually...
Yeah,
I wanted to...
Actually, I'll farm you for silk real quick.
Just in case.
I don't trust the going down part.
The going down part seems very dangerous.
Alright, then I'll not go.
Oh, there's a lot of music right now.
Hello?
Friendly?
Oh, she does not seem friendly.
She seems very mean.
She looks like a Karen.
I don't think she fun.
And I don't think I can leave.
I don't think I can leave.
I should have swapped my stuff.
Oh, um, they shall join.
Union upon your thread.
A gift for your waking.
A world strong to serve.
Creature, your claws guide those cursed threads.
But you are not the source.
What role do you play?
in this vile affliction.
Huh!
She is here.
The rare birthling precious child of worm and weaver.
Spawn of those who dare to flee.
She has found her way home at last.
How fine her shell and silk and claw.
For you mother, let me claim her all for you.
What?
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my what?
What?
What going on?
All right.
Okay, cool.
That's that's sweet.
That's every everything was going on.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
All right.
I felt like they just, everything was just there.
I don't know.
I mean, it doesn't really matter what I put here.
I don't even have much of anything.
I'll just use the compass.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
go back down
it is one is the elevator yeah
what the fuck why can't I excuse me excuse me fine then I don't oh my gosh I'm not okay
all right down I'll go
all right down I'll go back to Help.
Maybe I can like live for five more seconds.
I don't know.
Maybe if I'm lucky, I can live five more seconds.
Truly.
I know it's crazy to think about.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I need to remember that does that.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
That was my bad.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, so many.
I'm stoked.
There's just too many things going on.
There's too many.
What the fuck is that?
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
Jesus.
I need to remember that's what it does.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
I guess.
That's not fine.
No.
There you go.
Friend!
Oh, I'm lucky.
That's not fair.
Nice.
Okay, second try.
Alright, there we go.
Here we go.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
I was like, cool, second try.
JK, there's actually second phase.
Ha ha ha.
You really thought it was that easy?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's on me.
That's on me.
Oh my god, it's fine, guys.
Oh my god, there's so many balls.
Too many, too many balls!
My eyes are not.
There's too many balls on my screen.
There's There's actually too many balls on the screen.
Okay, I gotta focus.
I was like, yay!
Too many cooks?
Oh my god, are you serious?
Fuck you.
The random bullshit go!
Yeah, the random bullshit was not...
I don't know if I want to keep the bag.
I'm trying to think if I want to keep Pogo.
Fuck you, let's swap Chris.
I don't know that I think I want to do I'm going to do actually I'm going to do Reaper I'm going to trust my instinct I'm going to do Reaper today I am feeling really slow though in general
I don't know if I want to do I'm going to do this just because I want more attack Ah, fuck it.
Yeah, that's why I won't do this.
I don't think I need to unlock a second one, though.
That's the thing.
Alright.
Alright, I gotta adjust the speed, though.
That's so, that's only the worst part.
It's because every- it's now slower.
Everything feels slower now.
That's the only issue.
Oh my god, it's so slow.
Okay.
Bye.
Nice.
Holy shit, that's so slow.
So slow.
Okay.
Oh my god, my attacks feel so slow!
When?
Here we go.
Are you serious?
That's so unlucky.
All right.
Nice.
Oh my god, I don't know why I did that.
Friend!
my god damn it there you go wait no my magic wait i did that so i can use my map okay please come back closer please i still it's still in effect nice let me use my magic please i spent money on this oh god oh god nice that's why i still got the heal oh my god so much random there's too much Ah!
Ah!
Oh shit.
Okay.
I'm thinking.
Okay, I feel like...
If I do...
I need this.
It's so slow now.
I need more speed.
There's way too much random bullshit.
Oh, whoops.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
all right all
right there you go now i'm faster now i'm just as fast i think now i'm looking at now i'm fast speed speed go what slurp slurp that's right i'm so fast now
Okay, that was the plan.
I just gotta be...
I just gotta make my own speed.
Alright.
Actually, I'll use that now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
The ricochet?
Oh, no.
I have no more.
I drank all my alkyl.
I drank all my juice.
What do I do?
I have no more.
What the fuck?
I have no more juice!
No more liquid courage!
Are you serious?
Okay, I'm back.
Okay.
It's okay.
I didn't remember that does too.
There we go.
That's fine.
Nice.
Friend!
Okay.
fire nice okay no that's the random bullshit no there's too many on my screen there's too many random bullshit it throws me off it actually throws me off whenever there's random bullshit oh my I got...
I like panic.
I see too much balls on the screen.
All right, I've got... I'm locking in for real.
I'm for real locking in.
I don't... I don't know if I'm using the wrong crest or not, but...
I don't know.
All right.
Okay.
That's fine.
Now I'm fast.
Just as fast!
Oh shit, I need to remember that.
And why I forget.
Nice?
Okay.
That's right, I'm fast as fuck, boy!
I'm so fast!
Can't stop me!
There we go.
Oh shit!
That's on me though.
That's just me being a little stupid.
Oh my god.
That's pretty magic.
Nope, no more.
Oh shit, I didn't realize.
I didn't even see him.
Okay.
When?
What?
I don't know how that fucking happened.
Shit.
Oh my god.
I'm just being stupid.
Get back here!
I need my farm, my magic!
How am I supposed to farm my magic?
You keep running!
There we go.
Alright, random bullshit.
Okay, focus.
Starting now!
Oh no, I knew it.
Oh my, oh my god, never mind.
Not starting now, apparently.
Not now.
I lied.
It's not now.
It's absolutely not now.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
This is where I want to be.
Not really, but this is the best it's gonna get.
Realize.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, we'll try hunting Chris.
I'm trying them all.
I didn't even realize I was wall ground.
I was looking at the guys.
I was looking...
Well, dude, I like the speed, though.
The speed was good.
The panic, yeah.
I didn't know!
I didn't know I was walking!
I was too busy looking at him!
Damn.
I don't know if I could pogo him, though, with this.
Fast juice.
Oh, my God.
God, no, I don't like this.
No, oh my god.
I'm much more disoriented.
Never mind.
Never Never mind It's worse I don't know how to put oh my god.
It's so much worse It's actually It's so much I'm not okay I'm not okay Never mind.
I No hunter crest.
No hunter crest.
I've learned I It was not, I forgot what it was like with the diagonal.
I, I forgot.
Okay, we'll try one day.
We're trying all the flimsy.
I was not okay with that.
That actually, I was like, I was like, oh, I missed.
It's been so long, guys, you don't understand.
It's been so long since I, since I hopped diagonally.
It's because of muscle memory.
I was not used to going there.
I was like, where am I?
I was really like, where did I go?
Okay.
What?
How did that hit me?
Okay, I'm gonna...
That's so not fair.
That's actually not fair.
That is not, I'm, oh, what's going on?
Guys, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know.
Ever since I swapped my crest, it's all downhill.
Okay, I told you guys, today is an off day for me.
Today is an off day.
I'm regressing.
I'm not locked in, I'm locked out with her.
Okay, now I focus.
Oh, I wasn't supposed to do that.
JK already fucked it up
I'm actually regressing I I don't know what you guys I don't know what's going on.
I don't know
Okay Look at this!
So what's Colin having?
There we go.
Oh my god.
I need like to remember to...
Alright, locked in.
For real.
I swear this time.
I know I said that like 20 times, but for real, this time.
Oh, that's unlucky.
No.
input reading I swear to God that's an she's input reading me like how how did you know
she read me like a book I wish I had input reading
okay now I drink my special juice I
need to remember to jump for this There you go.
Got my parry in.
Oh my god.
I wasn't expecting her to run out my fucking face.
That's fine.
Walking in.
For real this time.
The other times we're alive.
This time, I swear to God, this time I am definitely locking in.
Okay.
Nice.
all right okay oh that was close i that was actually i was crazy for that god damn it stupid random bullshit god i hate you i hate you so much i hate this i hate this
rng is like literally rng is my downfall it's my downfall when there's too many things on the screen i just my eyes just don't know where to look i
i looked away no i'm locked out oh please please stop looking at me stop Stop looking at me.
I get like overloaded.
I just...
Too much stuff on my screen.
That I get super overloaded.
Don't look at me.
Don't...
Stop looking at me.
Thank God.
What?
Oh, it's too short.
Short problems.
I'm locked out again.
I'm locked out.
I think I need caffeine.
Oh, no!
My eyes feel so heavy.
No, you got this.
You don't need caffeine.
Guys, I don't know what's wrong.
I don't know what's around with me.
I'm locked in that gate.
Don't look at me.
Today's my off week.
Bring tired.
Okay, I did do the best with Reaper.
I agree.
Sometimes when too fast, my brain.
just don't know what to look at.
I'm just too fast.
Okay, that's fine.
I didn't even press it!
Okay, that's fine, I guess.
I swear to God, I didn't even press it.
Oh my God, of course you're in front of me.
I got him all over the place I've regressed I've I've returned a monkey
guys I think I've returned a monkey evolution
there you go I'm back I'm locked in but like the opposite side I accidentally locked myself Oh, instead.
No, no, no!
Guys, I think it's time to bring back the Reaper.
It's actually my best run.
Okay, I don't trust myself anymore.
I don't!
I just locked in directly into the bells.
All right.
My best run was the Reaper.
Yeah.
even though she's it's very slow slow crest for slow brain this is a slow brain day this is actually a slow brain day okay okay I'll stop yapping I'll stop yapping for real all right I drink drink my special juice
okay oh
my God, get over here.
Get over here.
All right, nice.
No, I ran into that.
Oh my gosh.
Get over here.
All right, nice.
Why?
Are you serious?
I'm sad.
Okay, nice.
No!
He always uses the moves I just don't expect.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, I'm fucking course you use that now.
I'm gonna throw my jar at you That's right, boom Okay, maybe I shouldn't have thrown my jar Maybe I shouldn't have thrown my jar guys Be such a bitch
I didn't even know it could do that!
I didn't even know it could bounce against...
Today's not a good day for Doki.
Prime Doki would have killed that boss like 30 minutes ago.
Can you stop?
Prime Doki would have killed her 30 minutes ago.
This is not prime.
This is why I'm Doki bugged.
This is why I'm Doki Bug, guys.
I'm Doki's on vacation right now.
Okay.
Just don't yap.
Lock in.
That's all you gotta do.
It's not that hard.
Alright.
That's fine.
That's not fine, but that's okay.
Okay.
So I make sure.
I just gotta be careful.
Getting into the pattern.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I forgot!
I forgot she does that.
Oh Shit That was my bad stupid fans
Yes, jump down
Okay, nice
Okay, that's fine.
I didn't think it still activates right after That's I that's fine.
That's fine.
Like, I'm okay.
I'm, I'm, I'm so okay.
I'm...
Are you sure?
No, no.
No, I'm...
That's fine.
I'm...
That's so fine.
That's fine.
Don't you keep saying you're fine, but we don't know.
We...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm fine.
I'm so okay with my situation.
I'm so okay.
I'm so healthy.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
That's nice.
It was so fine.
If you say...
Yeah, yeah, if you say so, you definitely sound so fine.
Okay.
I try to say I'm locked in, but, like, I think I locked myself in the wrong side of the door.
You're right.
There's only one thing.
Now I'm locked in.
Please, dad, please.
I'm not okay right now.
Oh my
god.
Please, dad, please, I'm not having a good day!
Oh my god.
What?
I like to speak to your manager!
Okay.
I like to speak to her manager, please.
All right.
Okay, that's fine.
It gave me a little bit of strength.
All right.
I think I actually have to just focus up and stop yapping.
This is the only way.
That's fine.
Good.
There we go.
Nice.
Parried.
I sure do love getting hit by the residue.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck you.
Okay.
I
got how many bells?
I want the bell economy to crash me.
right now!
Jesus Christ, that was my bet.
Oh, fucking course.
Oh, fucking course she sends!
It's okay.
I go through this pain for you.
I do it for...
Do it for them.
I...
Alright.
Guys, yeah, the boss is just trying to make you guys remember to ring that notification bell if you want to get more content just for like this.
Focus up, focus up, focus up, don't keep.
Don't let them win.
You're tired.
You're tired and today's not your day, but don't let them win.
Really?
Why?
Okay.
Alright.
That's good?
Oh my god, that's just me being stupid.
Let me get one more slash.
Nice.
Full magic now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No, not fair.
She was body blocking the only way!
That was actually bullshit.
I got this.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, that bell hits me.
She interrupts?
She can interrupt that?
No, I'm no longer locked in.
She can interrupt it with her yell?
I didn't know that!
I didn't know she can't...
I didn't know.
She can cancel you because she yelled a little loud.
She just decides to yell at me.
Now you know.
I was using Skull out because I wanted to farm my magic.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
She can actually do that.
We live in such a fucked up world.
The world is so fucked up.
The world is so cruel.
Oh my god, sometimes I forgot like...
Oh,
I'm gonna poke her a little bit more.
That's fine.
I got some magic I need.
No, please don't disappear.
Nice.
Why?
Why are you running?
Oh my god, I'm still mad.
I'm so mad
Let me poke you Let me poke you Please!
Oh my god You let me poke you after I fucking used up my magic shit Such a little bitch You're such a little bitch
I swear to God that bell hits me I swear to God, that bell hits me.
Too many
bells.
Too many bells.
What do I do?
My weakness.
My actual weakness.
It's the bells.
It's actually the bells.
Ah!
It's like the boulders all over again.
It's the boulders.
You don't understand.
It's the boulders all over again.
It's...
It's like the fucking boulders.
You don't understand.
It's like the boulders from all over again.
I can't when there's too many things on the screen I'm afraid overload I need to be a one-on-one it needs to it needs to be a one-on-one I can't handle it I just want to move
Okay.
A master of the first phase.
I'm gonna say that and I'm gonna die, aren't I?
You don't understand?
It's like the boulders, you don't understand.
The boulders...
The boulders were like so hard.
The boulders were like...
I...
I'm so sad I'm so sad
There's just something about the boulders It's just something about it
Okay All right
All right Me
and it floated instead I swear to guys There was a bug I pressed b and I floated I don't- I don't understand!
I press B!
That's it.
I'm bringing it out.
I'm going beast mode.
I don't care anymore.
I- I-goes beast mode.
There are bugs in my bug game.
I don't care no more.
I'm going beast mode.
The beast has been unleashed.
And it's going to be my worst run yet.
Wait, the dash is worse.
Wait.
Guys, wait.
The dash is worse, guys.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Run!
I'm going beast mode!
I'm letting the beast out!
Oh my god.
This is the downward is not good for this.
The downward is not good.
Run!
I'm letting it all out!
Get over here!
Okay, maybe I shouldn't have let the beast out.
Maybe the beast was a bad idea.
Oh no, this is bad.
I'm 2 HP.
Whoops.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, they even get chance to go beast mode.
I just got...
Guys, beast modes was a bad idea.
I don't...
That was a last of judgment.
That was...
That was a last of judgment right there.
Maybe no more beast mode.
I let the beast down.
We gotta keep the beast back.
Into the cage the piece gets gonna go back in Knock me out of the beast has been caged
Oh my god, okay, that was on me that that's also on me.
I'm I'm just messing about now
Focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus focus
Focus, focus, focus.
If I sit y'all focus hard enough, maybe I'll focus.
Focus, focus.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god, that was me being very greedy.
That's not how it is.
Oh my god, wait, I could have just done that.
what
okay that's bullshit oh goodbye friend goes goodbye bye-bye nice how do you guys know I looked at chat okay more actual focus okay for real I swear I don't know I don't anymore never mind I'm
so sad I'm so sad okay I'm okay no more distractions no more I lied the other times when I said no more distractions This is the quietest I'll ever be.
I swear to God, this is the quietest I'll ever be.
Look, today's my off day.
Nice.
Fuck
it.
This might be dumb.
But I want magic.
I want my free magic
I it's cuz I talked it's cuz I talked
No, I opened my mouth and it was over
My god
Okay Oh my god God
damn it Oh,
but I just have to stop talking I just had to stop talking.
I had to stop yapping.
I'm so sad.
Why?
Why am I a streamer that likes to yapp?
I just actually locked the lock in.
The yapper diva.
Oh my god.
You stop yapping?
I'll stop supporting Gamma Deku with a secret chat Where do I go?
Oh, is that a- I can't even tell.
I didn't realize that was a platform.
I slowly and I slowly flow down I don't understand and I slowly I'm so tired
Thank God they put journalism mode.
Thank God.
Alright, here we go.
Oh.
Just to thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Affiliate, I'm thinking for the five gift of ships.
Oh, now I play my music.
Today's not a dokey day.
I swear, it's literally...
I just can't comprehend random bullshit on my screen.
It's just too many balls.
I don't know.
It's too many.
There's like an appropriate amount of balls.
And those were not an appropriate amount of balls.
Those are far.
That was over the ocean limit.
The health inspector was not happy when he saw all those balls.
There's too many balls
It's really It's just the boulders That fight reminded me of the fucking boulders All over again
I felt like I was back in boulder town I was back for her light Eternal our song sustains
you don't understand birds are weak against rock and she was nearly using rock crash that's literally it gone gone gone gone gone but you're a bug a rock can crush a bug have you never fucking crushed up have you ever a rock at a bug?
You literally see a bug crying?
You drop the rock.
It's dead.
What the fuck do you mean?
Bugs are also weak against rock.
Where am I at?
No, don't see that to me.
Well, that's what happened to me for the last hour!
Where am I?
Oh my gosh, I forgot to put my compass back on.
I was like, where the fuck am I?
I'm so lost.
I'm tired and lost.
Oh my god.
This way.
Okay, things will be easier now.
As long as there's no more No more rocks.
It should be okay.
Okay, now everybody is freed now, right?
Hello.
La la la.
Welcome, welcome.
Wary pilgrim.
This glorious bell heart may be past as fond as shine is still remains the last friendly stop before the citadel.
There's a task of I, very blessed.
Pavel to extend the warmest of welcome To those passing devout.
So says You're a good self.
Yes, V.
Your town Seems to have returned a healthy form, good bug.
As some concern that upon cutting You're free, I find only us.
Yes, well, many Most of our rest is to not fare So well.
So it's No good to dwell on dark things.
We shall build and grow and welcome As is any good spellbugs Task.
Okay.
So the town is back.
a nail upgrade i was promised nail upgrade oh wait no calm oh my god thank god thank god capitalism has yet to hit bell town thank god i'm so happy oh wait no it's because i bought this already never mind this is the one thing i unlocked i forgot it's been a while reading shopkeeper it seems you've recovered well from that silk and affliction Huh,
well, I'm a clever bug.
When that strange thread struck down from above, I shut up tight and huddled in my bell home.
Must've been a problem for the others about here, but my store was flush with supplies, so no fear I'll go hungry.
Your preparedness served you well, then, although your store now seems quite bare.
Yes, I admit.
Weight was longer than I anticipated, and a bug has to eat.
I have more to offer you once my courier turns up.
No doubt he's been avoiding Bellheart since the curse said it sights on us.
Alright.
I'm broke as fuck right now so I can't.
Wait, actually I have several.
You know what?
Yeah, I actually have several dockets, I'm pretty sure.
Oh yeah, I do.
What do I need?
Yeah, I gotta open this then.
Alright, I can buy memory.
Alright.
Uh.
What's this?
Which promise?
I did the wish.
When searching, you can sometimes find rare.
If you can salvage some, the material would be of great use.
Okay, I got a bunch of those.
My dear little Kouras was last seen.
Please someone find Tip and send him home, along with all the precious stock.
So he was at...
Where again?
I took the quest without actually reading it.
Alright.
something.
Do I want to keep using memory or I still want to use Reaper?
Do I want to try Wanderer more?
I don't know.
I'll do Wanderer and I'll unlock.
Eh.
I don't know which one I want to do.
Do I want to lock something in Wanderer?
Hmm.
I keep Reapering it.
I'll unlock it on Reaper then.
Alright, and then so I can finally put...
Ew.
It's up top.
This one?
Oh, that's not...
You don't seem like an upgrader.
Come on, what?
Who is it?
What you've got?
What do you want?
I am just a traveler.
One hoping you are not too badly affected by the curse snare set upon the sound.
Ha!
What binds them outside needs nothing to me.
None of them have my keen sense, my respect for the past.
You see, Mabel, though, sneaky too.
They find any final stuff, anything of a history to it.
Bring him here.
Oh, take it.
Oh, Mitch, take it for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
But what's this?
I smell something on you right now.
You have a relic for me?
Yeah, sure.
Take it.
Yes, this is my collection.
Well, look at them.
Look at what I have.
What do you have?
Oh, nice, money.
Vaded parchment contained the last words of a lost pilgrim.
Eh.
Morning, bring me more relics of the past.
Record seals, idols.
Let's gather up the history of the world and hoard it all year.
Nice and safe.
If I have been upon more curiosities of this kingdom past, I may visit again.
Until that time, keep yourself safe.
Whoa!
Hey, Doki, don't upgrade.
No, I'm fuck off.
I'm upgrading now.
Mr. Broken Fond.
He's in a super chat.
Bro, I got...
Whoa!
Horton, I did not know you were like that.
Oh, my God.
I didn't know you came from the Xbox era.
It's my calling to gather the relics of the past.
Horton, no!
Look at my collection.
If you fancy, look, look.
Oh, I just want to have...
I just have one relic.
Unluck you.
Or it's a true gamer.
Oh, this has to be him, right?
By God.
Are you then our savior in the shell?
Standing so calm and cool on entries to Pliny's bell home?
What clues, sir?
Tell me.
Tell us on my part in your town liberation.
Why your beard, blade, pierced.
Why your blade, pierced warrior.
Any fine pin master will detect the sign of a deadly work upon that needle's edge.
I'll curse that struct here.
No simple bug, nor basic pin, could have granted our release.
No.
That blade, though, so expertly clutched in claw.
That could well have met the task.
It was you who cut us free, yes?
Winera.
I've granted you a sharp sight, Pin Master, and your savings is, fortuitous.
This blade that restored your town will now benefit from your service.
Well, yes.
pins to 10 but your gracious heroism decrees that unique weapon receives my care at this very moment what say i take a look yes please
thank god bosses now have control i don't care the bosses have quintuple health or does four times damage i am not doing this again i am not repeating my history
by my expert club your strange blade has received some fast sharp shine it shall cut cleaner than ever before your efforts provide great aid penmaster you have my thanks all right do i have more or is that one uh can the blade be honed further you seek further sharpening further than pilney does provide impertinence but maybe but no you're you hesitate then it is possible are you others within the kingdom oh i'm saying are you skilled if wait yes seek knock others but an oil fabled and fine with it the citadel once brought climbing edge and point to its pins though the citadel's pin masters are long past some small store of that miraculous elixir may return within this hall or even a mere mere drop pilfered and gifted upon plenty your blade could shine brighter still.
Just know, dear friend, the veiled bugs would be oh so unkind to the thief who claimed that fine prize for themselves.
I believe I could go down the street to get one cheaper.
He's like, wait, stop!
We match every price.
I will find the oil, pin master.
My needle has seen much use in this cruel kingdom.
I suspect many more battles are due.
I will value your further skills upon my blade.
it is dangerous wish you accept of this poor pin master i really hope this one's professional desire does not cost you your life perhaps oh oops sorry okay i just wanted to make sure if i if i had all the um everything is that it it should be it right
all right where do we go now guys where do we go go now chat what's the next goal also i remember it i also waited because then we someone will know how to unlock the stupid fucking chair like left of shellwood yeah oh here a goddamn stupid fucking chair the fucking scam
All right, left the shower.
I waited.
I was just so sad about that chair, so I waited.
How do I get there?
Okay, we just go there.
Let's go this way.
I'm sad.
Oh.
trap what what is over here oh makes me so confident when i don't have a map for this
now up when can i go up
hello the sand marks the edge of fireloom's territory i was brought to this land through the caverns beyond.
Something of this kingdom's height still hungers for me.
We're at Tafinio now.
Until I find the source of that hunger and steal it, I will not be free.
Oh, there's an invisible wall down there.
Imagine if I just leave.
I'm just like, alright, my job here is done.
Where that gap was?
Yeah?
Oh, here.
Except the of the rise beyond.
The all who stand at Farnoom's holy crest prove pure will and want.
Oh.
I thought that's where I played a music.
Up I go.
Oh, I'm doing the pilgrimage.
What's this?
That's the chair, right?
God pay the hobo tax.
Yay!
blasted steps oh my god all right i have to i have to go here okay okay i love it when my sand has a little bit of worm
that's my favorite part oh shit oh now i can't see wow worms and being in blind nice
What the fuck?
Oh shit, I want to do this.
Holy shit!
They're robots!
What the fuck was that?
Oh, yeah, now go.
Where does this go?
Oh shit!
Alright, nice.
Oh, it's just shells.
I get...
Oh, and I lost all of it.
Good shells.
Good investment.
Okay, up I go.
There's something here.
Oh, I don't have double jump so I can't go there.
Yeah, money!
What the fuck?
Get over here.
Oh, they're also trying to do the pilgrimage, and I'm stopping it.
They're like, please, I'm just trying to go to that pilgrimage with my religion.
I'm like, don't worry, I'll take you to your god early.
They're just trying to do, go to the holy land.
Don't worry.
I'm here to help you.
What's that?
Oh, he just jumped to his death.
Oh, dying.
Oh no.
Dying.
I hate this guy so much.
What the fuck?
That's fine.
Wait, that's not fine.
Wait, I didn't realize how low HP I was.
I was like, it's fine.
Alright, this way.
Gong, gong, gong.
Oh, wait, who are you?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he has this old little gun.
Oh, she's here!
I think I'm bro.
Hoshanka child.
Shakira!
Child wielding needle.
Have you seen Trace summon master in your vibe?
I feel she was only here recently.
I cannot say for certain, Shakira.
Though she travels seeking silk-yield opponents, these steps will serve her well.
them are formidable true impressive guardians they are fighting defensively and love to leave their station they swing their weapons with a cool retaliate that should not be underestimated oh I do have enough yeah I'm gonna survive the recession guys guys I'm
just gonna use that I don't I don't really care about wasting my managing.
Can I imagine if I could just...
Oh shit!
Okay.
Jesus Christ, this guy is annoying!
Nice, I was gonna try and hit him off the platform.
all right that's right you ain't going to the holy land i will be the only one that makes this pilgrimage there's gonna only be one one survivor here oh fuck it that would have been sad if i got hit by that oh my God, your magic is so far away from me.
Oh, fuck.
I'll send you to God.
I don't know, I'll just, like, Pogo here.
There you go.
Ow!
Not cool, buddy!
What?
How did that hit me?
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
I'm still alive.
Oh, nice!
Oh, it blows me further!
Yay!
I assume I'm not supposed to... Yeah, now that would like hinder me if I do that.
Okay, I made it.
What happens now?
Oh, okay.
I guess that unlocks the shortcut?
Oh, whoops.
Wait, I need you to die closer to me so I can rob you after I kill you.
After I roared your journey.
There you go.
God, the snakes are so scared.
They're like, it's dinner time.
Oh!
Yeah.
All right, I have to make sure where to go.
All right, just like that.
All right, I made it.
Now where did I go?
Left or right?
I'm going to go left.
Oh, left is trap.
Yeah, that's good.
I just think I have money.
Yeah, I do.
The sand hungers.
Be one with the sand.
Be one with us.
Come on, you know you want to be one with the worms.
And then I gotta pay again.
Oh.
What happened to the city?
What happened?
I know what.
And this is the nerfed version.
This is why the market crashed.
This right here.
The economy.
Inflation is so real.
This is why the market crashed.
market crashed in bug land.
What?
I can't even get up there.
He's like, hello!
I don't even know where I'm going.
Oh, it's a flee.
I was like, this has to be a flee.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Go this way.
I need to make sure I don't fucking fall to my death down there.
Wait, what is over there?
Alright, we go right now.
What's this?
Oh no.
Oh no, the sand.
What?
The sand's still hungers.
It's still hungers.
Oh my god, it's calling for me It's calling for my name.
Okay, I did not expect the dash.
When?
Okay, where do I go?
Not here.
So I didn't have to fly.
Wee!
Now what?
I guess this way?
It hungers.
Okay.
Can I kill him?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
That robot was depressed.
It was Gemini.
That was a Gemini robot right there.
Somebody fed him some code.
And it was over.
Wait, why is that over there?
Someone fed that poor robot some code.
That's a shortcut?
That did not tell short.
Wait, what?
Oh, it was just...
It was already dead.
Oh, fuck.
I was a little confused with that.
Do I have to?
Oh, that was a shortcut.
I didn't realize I should have gone down from there.
Wait, what's over there?
Wait, you guys saw that?
What's over here?
Secret?
Oh, nothing important right now.
Hello!
What's over here?
The gate, the gate, oh the grand gate, the citadel stands before us we are so close oh mighty one beyond the gate we beg you open the way and let we port insignificant little pilgrims crawl into the light i see no gatekeepers to heed your plea pilgrim though i too seek entry to the citadel have you heard of a means to open this gateway oh weapons blunt it not no holes for keys there's the bells they say the holy bells that opened the way.
On my journey up, I passed many large bells housed in old shrines.
I was struck awake, yet still this gate stayed close.
What are tasks must be done to see us passed beyond?
The bells are run, then the sacred threshold may now be crossed, but the final task is simple.
Only music played fair and true.
Music's how it tuned the bells and seeing a gate descend.
It must be you to lead us sister you who brought us this blessing players sing and we shall follow okay i can do that
thank you i just learned it an hour ago oh is that also supposed to happen pilgrims
It was their idea!
Yes!
Okay, thank God.
It was their idea!
I swear to God!
Not my father!
Three, four!
I don't know, fuck!
Okay, there you go.
Friend!
All right.
Oh my god three step wait wait does that do three wait guys I what what what what am I looking at
phase two dokey what oh my
god good thank god she's here i think i need some motivation right now i need a speed yo pilgrim no yo pilgrim sorry little pilgrim do you sleep hi there i was looking for somewhere to rest my worry shell and found this cozy station thank god she was here i need some music for my soul yo pilgrim what's up bro this these lands are dangerous i thought perhaps some I come to you.
Oh, red maiden.
Have faith.
No harm can come to us on this holy ascent.
We only need to keep our gaze upwards.
This is all so terribly grand.
The great stone steps, the winds lifting us like the voices of a choir.
And just beyond it all, does our pilgrimage's end.
The great citadel at last.
Sing for me.
Oh, the shadow bench has risen for us.
Barlooms kind as to we- I paid for this!
that my taxpayer money paid for your bench please rest red maiden and free not our kingdom watches out excuse me my i don't even live in your country and i have to pay taxes for your bench
aren't those solemn jug but judge bugs nice you don't speak or sing by sense great wisdom behind the glummy eyes the one wise or not their judgments are often followed by violence many of your fellow pilgrims have fallen to them on these great steps oh but even the fallen will sometimes stand again and all pilgrimages will be completed yes sure yeah all of them yeah don't mind yeah those those pilgrims i met they definitely completed them all right sing for me please we not see my death My string.
Guess we'll never know the end of that song.
Don't ruin this chat.
Like, funny.
We'll never know how that song ends.
Alright, we gotta swap this.
I guess we swapped this.
And then...
That's it.
A lot of people said it was a shortcut.
People lie.
Oh, fuck this.
I cannot be bothered.
Is it this?
How the fuck is the shortcut that I was lied to about?
Are
you serious?
Get out of here.
Like, how do I do this shortcut?
Oh, it's from here.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
I passed the shortcut already.
Oh, wait, the guy died.
That's good.
While I was trying to figure out the shortcut, he died.
Oh, no, not the worms.
Okay, that's the guy that can't talk.
Whee!
Okay, so like...
So like, it's a little bad that I already sort of messed it up.
Okay.
You think he got me?
Yeah, he did.
Okay,
I'm worried about the throwing thing.
Yeah, this one.
Yeah, this one I'm worried about.
Because I don't know when he used...
Jump!
Thank God.
I need all that magic.
Oh, no, not fire!
Play!
Oh, my God.
I don't know what to do.
Ah!
I slowly floated into her face.
Alright.
Okay, so I'm sort of figuring it out, but also not ready, really.
I mean, I think I hate that bug the most.
Okay, oh my god, I went the wrong way again.
I made the same mistake Because I got confused And then I forgot about the shortcut again I mean the runback It's not so bad
Unless this is like the nerf version of it This runback is not Yeah it's oh it's nerfed Okay yeah I was gonna say this is not so bad
Please jump when you jump I it's less scary for me
All right.
Oh my god this part Wait, oh my
god the fire
Oh shit.
What the fuck do I do?
okay I'm very scared
I'm very scared guys oh
he jumped he jumped holy shit I mean it's not rocks though at least I'm just happy it's not God damn it this guy this guy this fucking this guy needs to get a job he's literally like he has too much free chat he needs to get a job
I keep forgetting that's like not an actual real bug like he's dead
That's not his job.
He's literally doing this because he doesn't have a job.
Alright, I know that that's the fling.
There you go.
Friend!
Oh my god, not the fire.
A fire is scary.
Fire is scary.
Whoa!
Okay, that was an accident.
That was...
Oh no!
Scary fire!
Oh!
No!
Good, I jumped!
I jumped too early.
Fire.
Wow guys.
Fire hurt.
Who would have thought?
I hate him.
I hate this fuck.
Okay.
Yeah, I want to make sure are you serious.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god Like he's like blocking the way Okay, now I hate this.
I hate this run back only because of this one guy He ruins it for the rest of us
There you go This guy ruins it
I keep forgetting to use this run shortcut.
All right, next time I'll use the shortcut, guys.
And then she never does.
And then she never uses it.
When?
No!
Why you no jump?
Whoa!
Oh no, oh no!
I'm gonna go to the side.
No!
Wait!
He's such a bitch.
I can't even make sure I'm a sing for me.
Point and not.
So how do I do it?
How do I do the shortcut, guys?
I keep, I don't know.
Oh, the boys.
Where's the short?
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
I see shortcut.
Alright, now I figured it out.
Now I know where the shortcut is.
It's over.
Alright.
I just get to phase two and then she starts throwing fire.
And then I was like, fire bad?
Fire bad?
Who would have died?
Are you serious?
There you go.
Oh my god, I don't know.
Oh no, fire bad.
Oh my god, fire so bad.
Oh my god, fire is the worst thing I...
I didn't even get a chance to grab the magic.
oh my god fire is so bad oh my god what
do i i she she got me
when oh god
oh shit that was unlucky oh my god friend
Get me out of here.
There you go.
Are you serious?
No.
No, no, no.
Not the bad fight!
Oh my god.
Stupid bad.
Fire!
Holy shit!
Fire so bad.
These bosses, I did not realize how much worse they could get.
Fire bad.
Oh, whoops.
I got greed there.
Weeeeee!
Everything changed when the fire judge the attack.
Yeah, I already upgraded my nail.
I got plus one.
I just let that happen.
I was just like, fuck.
I think like, I will save.
Silk Sun, you have to be more aggressive.
For sure.
this looks on um for war it's like aggressiveness more like oh my like what do you what do i do in that situation
yeah i'll just do that are you serious like oh my god i can't i can't i can't get cornered get cornered there I
feel like you can't be passive and still sound compared to like hollow net you have to be so fucking aggressive with how you play
change tour oh wait I don't have oh I forgot I forgot to that I forgot to refill my honey my special juice Oops.
Oh, well.
That's fine.
Yeah, I forgot that I need to refill it at the fleas.
Are you serious?
I thought he was gonna jump.
When?
Oh my god, let me.
That's good.
Nice.
I need you to jump so I can get across.
Please, let me have my magic.
Oh my god, you're such a bitch.
Oh no.
No, not the fire.
I'm trying not to get cornered.
Are you sick?
I hate you.
Okay, let me, uh, let me change my thing.
Here we go.
I got column mode so hard.
I got outplayed.
What?
How did that hit me?
Fuck this guy.
Fuck you.
Okay, I might have wasted my shit there.
That's okay.
It's all about sending a message.
Not trying to get cornered but runs into that corner.
I can't help it!
The corner!
It speaks to me!
Do not hear it?
It calls my name.
I'm...
It's calling for me.
I'm gonna use it now.
Just in case.
Oh, now he does the jumpies.
What?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna hit by everything.
Fuck you.
Oh shit, fuck me.
Every single time.
Alright.
I couldn't heal.
I lived...
Oh my god, that shit was scary.
I almost got into that worm pit, I thought.
And what I'm not surprised by, the times 2 times 3 damage.
That's what I'm saying.
Just give me 3 masks if they're all just going to do times 2 damage anyway.
If you give me 3 masks and then make it so that If they all do one damage, then it's just the same thing.
Why give me this false sense of security?
Oh my god, that's my bad.
I fucked up that.
Oh my god, I'm in the corner.
Arrest it!
I will not be in the corner again.
Proceeds to put myself in the corner.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that was an accident.
I'm in the corner again.
I'm never there.
I'm never there in a fair league.
Oh my god, please.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of the corner.
Please.
Let me leave.
Thank god.
Okay, I'm out.
Oh shit!
That was an accident.
Oh, that was also an accident.
Oh no, I'm in the corner.
Oh no!
How?
Oh shit!
That's how.
Okay, I got really lucky there.
Fuck!
She says calmly.
I landed on her.
Alright, hee hee, thank you, welcome to tomato fight.
Welcome, welcome.
I don't remember I have two of these two.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Alright, alright.
Okay, I'm locking in.
That's it.
She's taking too long.
It's time.
It's time to lock in.
Oh, fuck.
I just wanted to ring that bell.
It looks so ringable.
Alright.
Is it?
Go focus.
Oh,
that's not me to do that.
Oh, fuck!
I didn't mean to do that!
This bad.
I actually messed up.
That's okay.
No, not the fire.
Not the fire!
Oh god!
please oh shit okay we're not okay we're not okay we are not okay i repeat we are every time i talk every time i talk i lose focus
i'm joking in the corner it speaks to me don't understand.
It's a very nice corner.
If you see it in person, you'd understand.
I can't help it.
It speaks.
It calls my name.
It's like, Doki, Doki.
Come back.
We missed you, Doki.
It's nice and dosi.
It's my little happy corner.
Oh my god, I hate that move so much.
Oh no, no, no, not the corner, not the corner, anything but the corner!
He does, like, the shot put throw.
And you remember which throw is, like, which throw is the one where he chucks it and which one when he swings it.
I think that's, like, what, like, I'm getting confused with.
Because sometimes I feel like it's the...
No, sometimes I think it's the one where she does the twerra.
I feel like sometimes she does the twirl but then she does the shot put and then that confuses me oh my god so I looked at chat so oh my god I looked at chat and then I got disoriented I
okay okay focus up focus up focus up this time
Yeah, but sometimes she like, I know you can't dodge, but like when she does the non-twirl, she like, she chucks it so far.
Like, see that's such a far chuck.
Oh my god.
Oh, the magic is over here.
But I just want to go.
Oh, no.
Friend.
Oh, my gosh.
That was an accident.
I wanted to grab.
I got greedy.
I got so greedy.
No!
Get me out of here!
Okay.
I'm so sad I'm so sad
I'm figuring out the pattern I hate this guy so much I hate that little mosquito That's it I'm going home I'm going home
It's literally I get confused.
It's the throw.
It's a fucking throw.
I don't know.
The range of her that throw could be anything
I'm slowly downloading it
Wee My
god you stupid you stupid
Oh what oh my god.
It's the I I forgot I forgot when she dashes a dash.
I got confused with my dash.
This is why I never use a dash sometimes for this.
Okay.
Oh, no.
A fire.
Fire, Oh, my God.
You are.
Fire so bad.
Don't get me out of here.
okay
okay stupid
fire move i hate that fire move so much
are you sick oh my god she threw it twice she threw it twice i didn't expect it to throw it twice I didn't expect her to throw it twice.
That was my first mistake.
I was like, I can go close to her because there's no way she's going to do that again, right?
Alright, that's cool.
No, I'm being... I'm so greedy with it.
Okay.
All right Okay Okay No, yeah, no, yeah, no, yeah Just full-on You play, you play, Doki, you play Just play
Oh my god That was close I almost actually got hit I actually almost got hit by that
Please jump again so I can pick this up Oh No
Fire Oh my god, that's so unlucky I got I got hit by the dash attack
When Okay
Okay Knew it
Oh my god
I fucked up that
No, I wanted to dash, but it gave me...
I wanted to dash!
Ah, that threw me off!
I was trying to dash and I floated for some reason.
No!
I got the right groove!
I think it's just that one enemy that pisses me off.
That little fly there.
He ruins everything.
The fly ruins it all.
Wee!
Okay.
Locked in.
Locked and loaded.
Eventually, if I say locked in enough, I will be locked in.
Not now though.
Unfortunately, it's not now.
Jump.
Nice.
See, that's...
to do that oh no fire fire fire fire fire hurts okay fire again fire fire fire fire all right
okay nice what that hits me how oh my god oh my god i shouldn't i don't know why i tank that i
Angry pee!
Pee done.
I have finished angrily peeing.
So it should be okay now.
It's just fire.
Like why are they all bosses that I'm weak against?
I don't understand.
Like this is a conspiracy theory.
it's all like this is like the type the like the type eating the shit on me why do what do you do that next up it's gonna be a fucking electricity boss or some
shit I don't understand I'm flying bugged that's like the most fucked up type advantage they could do to me
okay no yeah no yeah you yeah you lose your
It's already too late.
I've already lost it.
I've already lost my groove.
It's too late
There you go
No, no not a five
Okay Okay Okay,
that was bullshit.
That actually was bullshit
Are you serious?
Okay.
I hate that.
I hate that move so much.
Don't let her!
win oh
my god not the corner all
right are you what
i'm so sad don't let her do this don't let her rage bait you don't keep don't let her rage bait you when you kill her she is the sole provider for entire family so when you kill her her entire family will die she is a soul breadwinner when you kill her you end her bloodline cuz her kids will starve just remember that let that fuel you they lose her entire income I
hate her
I didn't jump because I hate it.
I hate my dash attack.
It like throws me off so much.
Okay, I know that her family aren't judges.
She's the last judge, which means...
Doesn't mean her fucking kids.
Okay.
This way.
Oh my god, that scared the shit out of me.
Oh yeah.
Here we go.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I don't understand how that hits me.
I'm just too close.
I get hit by a large ass head.
her head too big
are you serious it's oh it's a stupid fucking head it's her stupid goddamn head
i hate you i hate you no
i need a haters silently i need a haters silently doki just hate her How much HP does this bitch have?
Oh my god, you win.
I hate starting this move.
I hate that one bug as well.
I hope when I kill the judge, he loses his job.
And then he'll be homeless.
I hope he becomes homeless.
And because he worked his entire career doing that, he'll never find another job because his resume is blank because he signed an NDA.
He'll be like, well, how come you have four to five years?
A gap on your resume.
He's like, I can't tell you.
I signed an NDA.
If I kill him, he'll never have another job.
That bug down there, he loses his job.
His only source of income.
I'm going to be ruining two families tonight.
God, I hate that dash move.
It's so annoying.
Alright.
Please let me on the other side.
My magic meter is right.
Okay, I don't need it.
Never mind.
Right here.
Oh my god.
I almost fucked it up.
Oh, I...
I don't know why I didn't register.
I didn't register that that was the charge hit
When Jesus
All right,
I forgot to register for that friend
No, that was a mistake
Oh, I walked into that.
Why was that so long?
I did not really It was so long
I hit phase three I was like, oh, it's over and then I did like I didn't register in my head that it kept going I didn't register that in my head.
I was like, yay, it's over It's over I literally stood still and I was like, yippee I like I got past that part That's stupid fire.
Oh my god.
I made it.
Jesus.
Focus, focus, focus.
No yack, no yack.
Every time you yack, you lose your focus.
Sorry, I tank it.
Get me out of this corner.
Oh my gosh, she put me back in.
She put me back into the corner.
Guys.
Guys, she put me back in.
Oh my god, I put myself in the corner.
I need to stop doing that.
Jesus.
Oh no.
My one weakness, the corner.
Real.
Okay.
Fire, fire, fire, fire.
Oh!
Oh no, phase three!
Oh my god, it keeps going!
Oh my god!
Let's hope that doesn't fuck me up.
How many
faces you have, bitch!
Oh!
Finally!
you children oh shit imagine if I died oh my god we did it we did it that would have been fucking wild if I died there
I I was gonna have an epic pool last last words to her The last thing she hears before she dies
I actually have to be so patient with her Oh my gosh she was like such a She was a boss where I had to be like Super duper patient or I die She had so many phases I hated her I'm so glad like now her family will be homeless Because she was the sole provider And now I ruined that guy's job too Because now his boss is dead and now he has no job.
But, uh, think fucking it.
Fuck.
It's over.
And then, obviously, though, it just gets worse.
The bosses just get worse.
Oh, my God.
It's over.
Act 2.
Tutorial is done.
We finished the tutorial.
Machina's playing a motto of the Citadel.
I just have to pay for this.
Break the glass.
The glass is breakable.
Just rob it.
Riot.
Why can't I riot and just break the fucking glass?
Need a boot.
Where the fuck is my bench?
Why can't I just steal it?
I am not a good citizen.
I've committed murder.
Come on.
Here we go.
It's a tight fit.
Come on.
Got this.
Force it.
Oh.
Well, now we're stuck here.
Maybe it wasn't a good idea.
idea to just keep spamming the button the corner calling to dokey like it's a green goblin mask thank you super chat mr mcfluffinskins thank you thank you guys think i broke guys it was like this when i got here i closed my eyes and i saw myself at the bottom oh my god there it is oh thank god 15 what if i had zero groceries all right we're calling it here i'm not i feel longer if I keep going.
And I just say to this is a short stream.
Thank God.
Thank God it's only $15.
What a steal.
Wait, is there a boss fight in front of me?
Let's see it.
Oh my God.
I was gonna say what happened to my chair.
My chair.
Does this pay to sit?
the who's the mayor of this town i just want to have very calm words with him it's a soup oh my god i thought it was just legends and myths i can't believe super capitalism is real i i can't believe it there's super capitalism i wait what happens if i Leave.
Do I get sent back at the bottom?
It's a legendary super capitalism.
Yeah.
Like, what happens if I leave?
You rent the chair for one minute.
Oh my god.
That sounds even worse.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god, they do like crazy damage.
They are so tanky.
Conrad bugs.
They are here to destroy super capitalism.
Conrad.
That's why...
Alright, here we go.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm trying to find another bench right now before I call it.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Where the fuck?
Where is another bench?
Please tell me not all of them.
Please tell me they're not all paid a win.
Oh, I swear to God.
Where?
Where am I?
What is this new hell?
Where?
What is this?
what oh my god i swear to god i was on the platform i hated here i actually i hate this i i hate this i hate this
oh my god i just wanted a bench i that's all i wanted i literally that's i just wanted to find a chair that
I'm going back I can't I can't I can't deal with this I all I wanted was to find a chair to find a chair that was not paid a rent
oh my god wait
it used to two times that is that is evil that is actually so evil a crude map okay yeah see why can't I just take it like that I don't understand Oh my god, that is literally the only bench I could see.
I said, I'm going down.
I'm paying.
I'm enabling super capitalism.
It's too late.
I'm calling it.
I like how there's two of them.
It's like, I like how they gave us two benches to pay to sit.
See, guys, super capitalism actually works.
I can't believe my reward for being for beating fire judge is is super capitalism that was my lovely reward that they gave me today that I will be part of the problem I am just
I am prior I enabled this Nimbus thank you for the super chat thank you thank you capitalism phase two Mr. McFluffekins, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This error pisses me off in the best way possible.
11 out of 10, world building by TC.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What a lovely reward that Team Cherry gave me for beating the judge.
I get to pay for every minute that I get to sit on that bench.
Thank you, Team Cherry.
I won't have it any other way.
Hey, guys, I hope you get, I feel like I'm in New York City right now.
all right so rewarding you know they did that i remember i read an article that they that they um that they used to do that i don't know if it's new york city but i know it was in america because only amer only americans can think of such a brilliant way uh to to do phase two of capitalism but it was basically like god it's literally like this you rent a bench and if you don't pay for the bench the spikes come up so because like like now i think like now they're like okay that's like really fucked up we should just have the spikes come up during nighttime but like the original like the initial like beta test of those benches was literally like um the spikes would be up and then you have to you have to like pay like you have to use like coin like uh with coins you have to pause it with coins and then the spikes will come down after you pay for it and like timed and everything uh yeah it's like and it's not even like it's like their way of doing anti homeless bench but also like
monetizing it it's like real money uh i remember reading an article about it a long time ago i don't know i don't know if like if they still if they're still doing it But I think they I pretty sure they scrapped that idea
The anti-poor bench But anyway Anyway guys I'm gonna call it here I hope you guys all enjoyed today's stream It was I don't know if I say fun is the correct word To describe today's stream It was Definitely an experience.
I swear all the bosses I fought today Were actually like like anti-doki bosses like they they were hard like my hard counters It was like random bullshit everywhere
And then fire
It was my worst matchup today it They were actually my worst matchups out of all the bosses I fought today.
I swear to you, I deteriorated.
I actually deteriorated on the bell boss.
But anyway, guys, I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get the blood flowing.
And you stay up for me and to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Yee!